Why do we need another egg anyway?
It’s Patisserie Week.
Come on, Malcolm. Please? For me?
Malcolm? The chicken is called Malcolm?
Yeah, Malcolm Eggs.
Any chance we’re wasting our time here?
[Noel] To reach the final...
Come along, dear.
...the bakers must master...
Oh, it’s breaking and melting.
...Patisserie.
I’ve done it wrong. I’ve done it wrong.
I’ve done it wrong.
[Noel] With three
of the most demanding challenges...
Really pushed for time now actually.
...in one of the closest calls...
Oh, my God.
...the tent has ever seen.
[Steven] Do not crack on me.
This has been the hardest decision that
I’ve been involved with in eight years.
[theme music playing]
[birds chirping]
[Noel] The semi-finals are upon us.
Four bakers remain but next week’s
grand final only has room for three.
This week the pressure has just tripled.
You’ve got to be absolutely perfect here.
One small mistake can cost you
your place in the final.
[Kate] Patisserie Week’s about precision
and finesse.
So I just hope I’ve got enough time
to be able to do it
because I know I can do it.
Patisserie is very much the kind of stuff
that I love doing.
That’s not necessarily saying
I’m any good at it.
[Stacey] I was going to tone it down
a bit this week
and now I decided,
no, I’m not going to turn it down at all.
In fact, I’m going to turn it up.
[Sandi] Just three more bakes
to show Paul and Prue
why they deserve the chance
to become the champion.
[Sophie] I hadn’t dared
to think that far ahead
but now it’s in very close
reaching distance,
to say I’m a finalist would be amazing.
[Steven] I want to get to the final.
I want to prove to myself
that I am good enough.
Let’s leave that one there though.
[Kate] I am fully aware that I am here
by the skin of my teeth after last week.
Just going to give it my best shot.
[Stacey] I intend
on getting through to the final.
I thought I’m here,
I might as well give it a go.
Well, morning, bakers, and congratulations
on making it to the semi-final.
Just four of you left.
Absolutely no pressure.
I can feel your relaxed vibes from here.
Now, it’s Patisserie Week
so for your Signature Challenge,
Paul and Prue would love you
to make 24 choux buns.
Now your choux buns need to be light and
airy filled with two different flavours.
Half of them must be iced and the other
half must exhibit a perfect craquelin,
that’s that crunchy sugary bit on top.
I love a bit of craquelin.
You’ve got two and a half hours.
-On your marks.
-Get set.
Bake.
At least where there is 12 of you,
there is quite a lot of people to leave.
Now, it’s just like, this is it,
one more person.
The worse thing that can happen today
is the choux buns don't rise.
They are too irregular. The tent caves in.
[Paul] We've asked the bakers
to make 24 choux buns.
What we’re looking for
is a crispy outside,
beautiful and airy on the inside and
the flavours must compliment each other.
From the icing on the top or the craquelin
to the unctuous filling inside.
Craquelin.
It’s a thin dough that goes on top
of the choux pastry
and bakes in the oven with it.
And it comes out
with crackly, crunchy top.
We’re expecting exquisite pastry.
This is their chance to show us
how good they actually are.
Are they worthy to get into the final?
I’m making a craquelin topping first
so that I can put it in the freezer.
[Steven] It’s a mix of sugar,
flour and butter
and you place a little disk
on top of each choux bun.
It’s basically a little jacket.
A little jacket for your choux pastry.
As it bakes, as the choux puffs
it splits it apart so you get craquelin.
Oops.
Good morning, Steven. How are you?
Good morning. Very well. How are you?
Very good. Tell us all
about your choux buns.
craquelin. We’ve got
a wholemeal coconut top.
Wholemeal?
Wholemeal flour. Because the centre
is a key lime coconut cheesecake.
-It’s almost back to front?
-Yeah.
[Noel] Not content with transforming
choux into cheesecake,
Steven’s also turning buns
into bakewell tarts using frangipane,
crème pâtissière and raspberry jam.
I know you quite well now, so when
you’re a little bit more stressed...
The eye twitches.
You get bright little bright red cheeks.
It’s been a pretty rough week.
It’s a combination
of developing these recipes
and knowing that this carries me
through to the final.
-The pressure’s on.
-Thank you very much, mate.
-[Prue] Good luck.
-Thank you.
[Paul] Thank you.
Just rolling out the craquelin
between two bits of parchment.
[Noel] Accuracy is the key
to perfect craquelin.
You have to roll it out
till it’s very thin.
About two millimetres.
[Sandi] Too thick and it will prevent
the choux from rising.
I did rush that a bit and I’m not sure
I’ve done it very well.
See, I’ve got some bits of sugar there.
I want to do it again.
I’ve upped my game for this
and it’s just so important.
[exhales]
[Paul] Good morning, Stacey.
It seems to me you always do
twice the work of anybody
because you quite often start again.
[Stacey] Doesn't take long
but I just need to do it properly.
-Right, tell us all about your choux buns.
-One’s choux-mojis.
[Sandi] Choux-moji.
And the other ones
I’m doing choux-nicorns.
Choux-nicorns.
Would you tell me how it’s going
to look like a unicorn?
Well, it’s not going
to look like a real unicorn.
Did you just say the words
"a real unicorn"?
[Sandi] Stacey’s cramming
her iced choux-nicorns
with multicoloured crème pâtissière
and filling her choux-moji’s
with banoffee cream
before piping faces
onto yellow-dyed craquelin.
You like girly things
and things for children.
I didn't want
to just have a boring choux bun.
I wanted to go for something different.
[Paul] Sometimes you go
too far down the overall effect
and forget about the bake.
It’s about finding that balance
between great flavour,
great texture and making it look like
it should be
in the front of any patisserie shop.
Hopefully it will work
and hopefully you will love it.
And you’ll want it
for your next birthday party, Paul.
I’ll give you a call. Thank you, Stacey.
Yeah, I’m happy with that.
That is going in the fridge.
[exhales]
The start of my choux pastry.
[Noel] Unlike most pastries,
choux must be cooked before it’s baked.
It just seems really unnatural
to make pastry in this way.
[Noel] Twice the chance
for it to go wrong.
So I’ve just got the butter melting.
When the butter’s melted,
I'll bring it to the boil,
put the flour in
and then start making the choux.
Right, this is the craquelin,
which needs to go in now.
I’m making the choux.
Got to get on.
I'll go get my flour ready
because that’s got to be poured in
exactly the right time.
You have to add it in one go
and then you have to beat it furiously.
[Steven] I’m just trying
to avoid any lumps forming.
It needs to be totally smooth.
You want it
to come cleanly away from the pan.
Just treating it quite nastily.
I’m doing a strawberry and rhubarb.
So it’s going to have vanilla craquelin,
the strawberry and rhubarb crème pat
and a white chocolate ganache.
Got to look like it would be in a shop
front of a little French patisserie.
[Noel] Sophie also hopes to bring
the flavours of French patisserie
to her choux,
filling her chocolate fondant iced buns
with a classic vanilla chestnut mousse.
We went to Paris and had the Mont Blanc,
which is a French delicacy
and it’s made with a chestnut purée.
Yeah, it’s lovely. I think this particular
challenge plays to your strengths.
It’s the kind of stuff that I love.
-That put more pressure on you?
-Yeah, a little bit.
Because then they’ll be like,
oh, patisserie, eh? A bit disappointing.
Are you feeling the nerves?
This week in particular,
a little pang in the stomach.
-The butterflies are coming.
-Yeah.
-Good luck.
-Thank you very much.
[Sandi] When it comes to flavours,
Kate’s taking her buns on a European tour.
-Kate. Choux buns?
-Hello.
So I’m doing Valencian orange
and brown sugar with a craquelin top.
And I’m doing a Bellini one
with prosecco and peach cream.
How are you making the peach cream?
I’m making a, sort of, like peach purée.
You’re not using
any artificial flavours or...
I am using a little bit of prosecco
and a little bit of peach.
-Prosecco artificial flavour?
-Yeah.
Wow, could you just
add prosecco flavouring to fizzy water?
I was made up when I found it.
[Sandi] With her crème Chantilly inspired
by the famous Venetian cocktail
and her Valencian orange crème pâtissière,
Kate’s aiming to capture the fresh
flavours of both Italy and Spain.
Sometimes when you’ve introduced
flavours in the past,
they haven't come through,
or they have come through too strong.
It’s about finding that balance
and making sure it’s right.
But I do think she’s got good ideas.
I mean, both of those flavours
could be absolutely fantastic.
-Listen to that and you come with me.
-Thank you.
-Thank you, Kate.
-Alright, thank you.
I’m putting the eggs in now.
This is the most important bit
of the whole thing.
[Sandi] The wrong amount of egg
will scupper choux
before it even hits the oven.
If you put too much egg in it,
there is no way that you can save it.
You’ve just got to start from scratch.
You can’t really follow a recipe.
You just have to go by eye.
[Noel] Over egg and the mix won’t puff up.
Under egg and the buns could collapse.
[Kate] It looks lumpy
before it starts looking okay.
So you’ve just got to work through
and have confidence in it.
[Steven] One test for finished choux is...
That peak should fall over.
Little bit more egg.
Little bit more.
It’s almost there.
That’s good. I’m quite happy with this...
Basically, how it looks.
I don't know. Kind of like that.
Cool. I think we’re there.
Right, we need to start piping these now.
-Hello, Kate. Are you excited?
-Yeah.
Is it hard not to think about the final?
-I’m not going there.
-Do you dream about the final?
Yeah, but I’m not in it.
[Steven] I do really want to try to get
this equal shapes and sizes.
But it’s so difficult.
You seem very calm.
That’s making me a little bit nervy.
I do yoga.
Do you do it with the other bakers?
No. But we should try it.
I’m in. Me and Paul.
I don't know if Paul’s got
the sort of right kind of...
-He’s very flexible.
-Is he?
Paul is...
His forward roll is honestly
better then his Swiss roll,
if I’m completely honest with you.
Just flatten them out
using a bit of water.
It will encourage it
to grow into a ball shape.
Sophie’s particularly good with this.
[Sophie] "Sophie likes patisserie.
Sophie’s good at patisserie.
"This should be your week." That’s always
a bit of additional pressure.
I’m gonna put them in now
and just see what happens.
Twenty minutes.
[Sophie] Got to get them nice and crispy.
It’s all about cooking time.
[Steven] Start them off at 20 minutes
and then I’m going to monitor them
after that amount of time.
[Sandi] Perfect patisserie isn’t just
about precision baking.
Right, we are going
to start on the curds, jams
and crème pâtissière for the fillings.
[Noel] Paul and Prue
will also expect finely tuned flavours.
[Kate] Loads of Valencian orange in there
so it’s a bit more sweet.
This is going to be for my crème pat.
Strawberries and rhubarb
and some rhubarb syrup.
I love this combination.
I just think it’s lush.
[Stacey] This is my crème pat.
So I am colouring them.
Pink, yellow and blue.
And when you cut into it
you’ll get a delight. They look the nuts.
This is the frangipane crème pâtissière.
I like this. It’s like a little
Alice in Wonderland bottle.
What’s happening here?
That’s almond extract.
Drink me. If I drink that am I going
to get small or big?
Not as small as Sandi.
Genetically impossible.
[birds chirping]
Right, my lovely bakers, you are halfway
through the time for your choux buns.
Halfway through.
Coming out the oven.
Thinking a couple of them aren’t great.
I think I would have liked them
a little more puffed.
They’re looking okay. Nice and crispy.
Starting on batch two now.
Just piped another load of choux buns
and they’re going to have
the craquelin on top.
You just want it, just a nice little
coating of it around the edge.
So I’d do quite a big piece
because I almost like
the whole of the bun enrobed in it.
-Not stressed, are you?
-I’m never stressed.
You looked
a little bit nervous earlier on today.
-Did I?
-Yeah.
-When?
-Was that an accident?
Probably needed the loo or something.
[Steven] Right, so these sit proudly
on top of their little choux.
This needs to go in now.
[in a sing-song voice] In we go.
There’s no calming down today.
I’m making the toffee sauce
that’s going in the banana choux buns.
I think more than anybody
I’ve given myself so much to do.
I’m such an idiot.
I’m just about to start
making up chestnut purée.
This is pulsed from fresh chestnuts.
Still loads to do. Loads and loads to do.
Peach and prosecco in that.
So like the normal flavours
of like a Bellini.
I like how much mess you make.
Do you?
See, I don't agree with them.
Paul always says tidy worktop,
tidy mind, you know.
Do you know what? I reckon Picasso
used to just get paint everywhere, so...
That’s what I mean. I don't imagine
that Van Gogh was hoovering, do you?
I’ve zested some lime
into this pan of sugar.
This is going to be the lime curd.
Got to get style and substance.
These are my unicorn horns.
Unicorns are pretty
and magical and I love them.
Right, I don't know what’s going on.
The toffee's wrong.
Just feels a bit grainy.
I keep doing things wrong.
I’m having a very, very, very, very, very,
very, very bad morning.
[sighs]
Please.
Got to do it again.
Let’s just hope it works this time.
Because I need it to work.
Bakers, you have one hour remaining
and if you don't finish,
Mr Spoon’s going to be angry.
[Noel] craquelin bakes quicker
than the pastry it’s covering.
So a perfect balance of time and
temperature is more critical than ever.
They’re not far off.
[Noel] And it’s even harder
to tell if the choux is done.
-[Kate] Should be nice and crispy.
-[Steven] Coming out the oven.
They’re a bit softer
but the craquelin on top was burning.
I think I should have done them
at a lower temperature.
What was that tap? They sound good.
It doesn't... It didn't achieve anything.
I don't know.
They look a bit burnt in places.
The craquelin’s come out really nice.
Just a case of assembling now.
Getting these cooled down.
Bakers, you have half an hour.
Just 30 minutes left.
Really pushed for time now actually.
It’s going to be tight.
I need to start piping these now.
Frangipane. Right, let’s get this done.
So I’m filling the buns
with vanilla and chestnut mousse.
So what’s happening here now?
Okay, so I’m glazing them quickly.
Yep.
I’ve done it wrong.
You’re supposed to fill them first
before I glaze them.
I’ve done it wrong. I’ve done it wrong.
I’ve done it wrong.
This is the peach Bellini.
I feel like I’m your carer
and I’m just coming in to visit you.
So how’s it going for you here?
So you’re making choux-nicorns.
I’m making choux-nicorns.
Okay, I’m going to send the nurse in.
Ooh.
Filling up my crème diplomat.
Making sure I get them full.
Pierced right the way through
the choux bun.
Oh, and it’s come out the side.
This is the orange crème pat.
It’s limey, which is just what I wanted.
Don't know how long I’ve got.
Bakers, you have just 15 minutes left.
Not very much time left at all.
I’ve got to get these iced as well.
Uniformity is key.
They don't look like something
you’ll see in a pastry window.
It’s messier then I would like.
Just trying to get rid of the excess
because I don't want it to drip down.
They’re not identical, that’s for sure.
I’ve got to show
that I can make something look pretty.
It's gonna be a bit of a crazy dash
to the finish line.
Gold leaf makes everything look better.
Do they look like horns to you?
Pick it up. Pick it up. Pick it up.
Oh, God.
Right, bakers, your time is up. Stacey!
I’m trying to put them on.
Stacey!
Please place your signature choux buns
at the end of your station.
[Sandi] The semi-finalists' choux buns
now face the judgement of Paul and Prue.
Hello, Steven.
They look a bit untidy. And burnt.
They’re quite flat.
I think your craquelin
was probably a little bit too thick.
It has restricted the growth.
[Prue] Let’s have a go.
Wow. Okay.
I definitely think this is under baked.
The choux pastry is too soft.
Very soft. I think the craquelin has
kidded you into thinking they’re ready.
Oh, it tastes great though.
It tastes exactly like a key lime pie.
That is absolutely delicious.
It just doesn't look good.
I think you’ve done this on purpose
so they don't say style over substance.
The bakewell ones
look very untidy as well.
[Steven] Yeah.
It’s a bit too sweet for me.
Bloody gorgeous, mate.
They just taste heavenly but look awful.
I think you have to eat it like that.
[Noel] Just dim the lights.
They do look beautiful.
Very nice shine on the chocolate.
All of those are the same size.
They do look a little bit flat.
I think it’s under baked.
Okay.
See how white that is there?
That could be darker.
Okay.
That’s kidding you that it’s ready.
So as it's sat and rested,
it’s just collapsed slightly.
Let’s have a look.
I don't get the rhubarb.
I get the strawberry.
The strawberry is stronger
than the rhubarb.
Yeah. Great flavour though.
And the craquelin’s nice and crisp.
Okay. Now these look a bit flat as well.
It’s very nice but I'd have liked
lots more chestnut.
It’s drowned by the chocolate.
I almost feel
a tinge bit of disappointment.
Oh, don't say that.
This is the semi-final and we really
are after absolute perfection.
I think they look really lovely.
All the ones with the brown craquelin
are the same size
and all the ones with the heart
look roughly the same size.
The craquelin has worked.
I think the colour is good.
It’s a beautiful golden brown.
We’ll start with the Valencia orange.
Yeah.
This is how I like to see
the choux pastry.
Soft in the middle
and crisp on the outside.
Mmm. Very nice orange taste.
The craquelin, it’s unbelievable.
I think the filling is delicious too.
I just think
you could have had more in there.
Now this is the peach Bellini.
That’s delicious.
Oh.
You have that peach in there.
You do get the prosecco flavour.
It really works.
Very, very good.
-Thank you.
-Well done.
Well done.
Thank you.
This one is most unicorn-like.
I had to rush the eyelashes and things
and then I dropped stuff anyway,
it was a bit...
That’s a sentence
you don't hear very often.
"I had to rush the unicorn eyelashes."
They are a mess.
Oh, my goodness, look at that.
-Oh, come on.
-Fascinating colours.
I’m not sure it looks delicious.
It looks amazing.
You did such a lot of icing.
It’s very, very sweet.
-Yeah.
-It’s a bit sickly.
The craquelin.
I don't like the yellow colour.
Just trying to make it a colour.
Just trying to make it a bit different.
Looks like curry.
I hope it doesn't taste like curry.
It looks burnt as well. You’ve got
a dark bottom to the choux bun.
These are banana cream and salted toffee.
Mmm.
The flavours inside are good
but your textures are all wrong.
Not your finest hour.
The risk I took, it didn't pay off.
And yet again
I kick myself for not making it simpler.
A shame that they didn't look great
but not too disappointed.
I’m so pleased about the flavours
because I lose out on flavour quite a lot.
Yeah, I'm relatively happy
with those comments.
Well, I am very happy with those comments,
not relatively happy.
What am I talking about?
The criticism is definitely harsher
because it’s the semi-final.
Nail the technical.
That’s what I need to do.
Wait and see what it is first.
[sheep bleating]
[Noel] What the bakers don't know
is that the recipe
they are about to tackle is the most
complicated ever set for a technical.
Right, bakers,
it’s time for your Technical Challenge
Now, it’s Prue’s first semi-final as well
so who better to set it for you then her.
Any words of advice?
We're after finesse, elegance
and every element,
and there are lots of them, counts.
As ever the technical
will be judged blind,
so we’re going to have to ask
these crazy kids to leave the tent.
Off you go.
Prue has asked you to make
nine Les Misérables slices.
This is a traditional Belgium cake
with a pistachio and lemon joconde sponge,
crème au beurre
and tempered chocolate decoration.
I know that sounds complicated
but in reality it is complicated.
You have three hours.
On your marks.
-Get set.
-Bake.
Oh, my God. Never heard of it.
This is insane. Look at this. Two pages.
Prue’s made it up. It isn’t even
a real thing. She’s just making stuff up.
I’ve seen them. They do exist.
Flicked past it in one of my books once.
Probably the kind of thing I looked at
and thought, no way am I making that.
Les Mis was some tragic story, wasn't it?
[birds chirping]
So Prue,
why have you chosen Les Misérables
for the technical challenge
in the semi-final?
Because it’s about
the most difficult thing I could think of.
I mean, one of the difficulties
is getting those layers.
It’s quite complicated
how it's stacked up.
The crème au beurre is in three layers,
one of which is raspberry.
And then you have four layers of
the joconde, two of which are pistachio.
Name me three things
that could possibly go wrong.
I can name you 20
but I’ll start with three.
Uneven layers. Scrambled egg crème
au beurre. Over baked sponge.
But I can go on.
So, make the joconde.
Whisk together 150 gram of caster sugar
and the whole eggs.
I think this challenge
plays to my strengths
but so did the choux buns apparently.
I need to put in egg whites super gently.
Don't want to lose the volume.
If I don't do well in this,
I might as well not come tomorrow.
Right. Divide the mixture
between two bowls.
Flavour them.
This is the lemon zest in this one.
And one’s going to have pistachio paste.
And some green food colouring.
How much food colouring,
that’s the question?
So I’m just going
to gently streak a little bit in.
I don't want anything garish because
Prue’s asked for an elegant sponge.
[Sandi] Oh, that’s very green.
I love the fact
that it’s bright green. It's so me.
Yeah. You. Your shirt. My shirt.
And that sponge...
-Rocking it.
-...green.
Right, let’s get these in the oven.
It says, bake I bet you.
Yeah, bake. Love it.
I don't really know how long it needs.
Just do five minutes.
I’m going to go eight minutes.
Right, crème au beurre, which I thought
he said crème herbert,
as in his name was Herbert.
From what I can remember
from GCSE French, buttercream?
So you heat the sugar,
pour it into egg yolks, add butter.
We are adding the beurre
to the crème au beurre.
I need it to be quite firm.
[Noel] Firmness is crucial
to a perfect slice.
Although we’re on the clock,
I do want to do this bit slowly.
If they go too fast,
it could all become a gloopy mess.
[Stacey] I feel it should be thicker.
One minute. I’m stopping for a minute.
Got a feeling that’s not right.
My buttercream’s quite runny.
Might be completely wrong.
Oh, no, no.
You’ve summoned me up like a genie.
I said, "No, no, no."
Oh, I thought you said "Noel", sorry.
Maybe get it in the fridge.
I’m just starting again. Round two.
I think I was supposed to
put it in slowly over time.
Feel like I’ve got to get a move on now.
Bakers, you are halfway through
your Les Misérables slices.
[Steven] Right, layering.
Putting the jigsaw puzzle together.
Paint this with chocolate.
And place chocolate side down in the tin.
And reversing the sponge.
It’s in.
Vanilla crème au beurre.
Pistachio sponges.
It’s all about precision.
When you cut into it,
you’ll see all the layers.
You want to try
and get them looking pretty.
[Kate] Ugh. Just a little bit too runny.
Top with one of the pistachio sponges.
It’s not very green.
Have you ever done this before?
No. Never. Have you?
-Yeah.
I make this all the time
at home with my kids.
Les Mis cake.
That don't exist.
[birds chirping]
Bakers, you’ve got one hour left.
[whispers] One.
There’s a huge amount of decoration.
So I’ve got to temper the chocolate.
I’ve never done it before.
[Stacey] I’ve never tempered chocolate
in my life.
Do you know what I usually do?
Melt it. Use it.
[Steven] To temper chocolate,
you heat it to a certain degree.
You have to raise the temperature
to loosen up all the crystals
and then we’re going to reform them
by cooling it quickly.
Who would do this? Belgians do this.
Maybe cool it down with some ice actually.
Do you know what?
I’m going to do it the sexy way.
Using a slab to cool the chocolate
and then do a bit of that.
Pour over the acetate.
Leave to set slightly.
I’ll probably stick it in the fridge
if I was setting it
but I don't think
it wants to be in the fridge.
Not a clue.
Score it.
I’m not even going to look round
to see what everyone else is doing
because I can guarantee you now
that it’s probably not the same.
Got no idea what I’m doing.
No, I can see that.
It’s not really scoring very well.
That’s not set.
Do you think if we just stand
and stare at it something will suddenly...
Yeah.
You’ve just got to wait
till it’s that perfect consistency
so that you can score a line
and it won’t close back up again.
Right. "Leave to set in the chef's rings."
Why have they given us two rings?
You have a wave of...
And then it would have to be like
a curled triangle? Can’t envisage it.
Ahh, I get it now.
I’m really overthinking this.
[birds chirping]
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
"Remove the cake from the tin."
Come on. Come along, dear.
This is not when I want to drop it.
Oh, all the chocolate’s peeled off. Ugh.
"Divide into nine equal squares."
I’m terrible at maths.
Three times three is nine, isn’t it?
Top with freeze-dried raspberry powder.
I’m going
for the put as much on as possible.
What on earth is going on with this?
[Steven] This being a semi-final
there’s a constant worry.
But I hate worrying
because it doesn’t get you anywhere.
-Ugh. It’s breaking and melting.
-Never seen such a mess.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Right, bakers, time is up.
Please bring
your Misérables up to the table.
Paul and Prue are looking for nine elegant
Les Misérables slices with defined layers,
firm but smooth crème au beurre
and light, airy, joconde sponge.
Right, we'll start with this one.
I rather like the harsh colouring
because it looks so pretty
but the chocolate is a bit of a mess.
Let’s see what it tastes like.
The crème au beurre is quite nice
and so is the joconde.
Just needed to be neater.
Right, moving on. I quite like this.
Looks very neat.
I’m very impressed with the chocolate
and it’s held its shape beautifully.
Yeah, I agree. Let’s have a quick look.
Well, it cuts very nice.
joconde’s good. It’s light, it’s airy.
Pistachio is there as well.
[Prue] It’s lovely.
[Paul] Moving onto this. It looks untidy.
There’s no definitive layers there.
This raspberry in the middle
looks a right mess.
It tastes lovely but it’s hardly
the elegant patisserie that we were after.
Right, moving onto the last one.
This looks quite neat actually
but pistachio could have done
with being a little bit greener.
The chocolate curl is a bit too gold,
it should just be a tiny dusting.
The sponge on that,
do you think it’s light and airy?
It’s not the best.
[Noel] Paul and Prue will now rank
the slices from worst to best.
Okay, in fourth spot is this one.
Whose is this?
You’ve lost all the definition
and it just looks highly untidy.
In third place is this one.
It’s good but it’s not the best sponge.
In second place is this one.
It was very tight between two and three.
Your sponge is better.
And that leaves Sophie.
It’s a very beautiful Les Misérables.
Congratulations.
Really needed it,
so I’m really, really chuffed about that.
What happened there? Tomorrow’s a new day.
I always say this
when I do really badly in the technical.
I am so relieved. I have to get
my head down and work super hard.
I’m just disappointed in myself.
Tomorrow for me is incredibly important.
[Sandi] Just one more challenge stands
between the bakers
and a place in the final.
Semi-final week. Patisserie Week.
How is that going?
The pressure is ranked up
and I think they all felt it.
Look at Sophie,
I thought her flavours were
not particularly good in the signature.
-And yet her Misérables...
-They were perfect.
[Paul] I think Stacey struggled
in the signature.
She is really feeling the pressure.
[Paul] The choux buns just
weren’t good enough.
Steven’s flavours yesterday
in the Signature Challenge
were delicious but they did look a mess.
We’ve always said flavour is the thing
that really matters.
The flavour wins out over aesthetics.
Absolutely.
So Kate has been see-sawing again.
She had a brilliant Signature Challenge.
I think her flavours were fantastic.
Loved the prosecco in her choux buns
and the craquelin on the top
was absolutely perfect.
But unfortunately for Kate
she then came bottom of technical.
It’s really tricky
coming into the Showstopper.
They know three of them
are going to go through to the final.
And that is a very, very big thing.
To get to the final
the bakers must take on
the most fragile showstopping structures
they have ever faced.
Well, morning, bakers, and welcome to your
very last challenge before we find out
who is going through to the final.
For your Showstopper Challenge,
Prue and Paul
would like you to make
a sculptural centrepiece out of meringue.
The judges would like to see at least
two different types of meringue.
Either French, Swiss or Italian.
Your meringue masterpiece
must be embellished with dessert elements.
You have four hours
and 45 minutes to create
your fantastic sensational
meringue showstoppers.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
Bake.
Showstopper in the semi-final. No. Nuts.
It is a bit more serious.
Not nearly as much banter.
We want them
to make sculptural design in meringue.
They have to almost to be architects
and engineers as well as bakers
because they’ve got to
design this thing to support itself.
Choose the wrong meringue,
the whole thing will collapse.
They must also have some dessert element
like curds and mousses or creams.
Because a meringue is so sweet,
I would like to see something with
a bit of acidity. It must taste fantastic.
They’ve got to come up with something
that brings their personality
into the bake
and books their seat into the final.
I think everybody is up against it today.
Next week is the final.
I don't want to think about it though.
I’ve got meringue to make.
I need to nail the whole thing today.
Absolutely need
to nail every element of it.
-Good morning.
-Good morning. How are you?
[Paul] Hello, Stacey.
Tell us about your meringue centrepiece.
I’m doing flamingos in love.
I’m in already.
So I’m hopefully going to have
two flamingos looking at each other.
Do you know
what a gang of flamingos is called?
A flamboyance of flamingos.
-Is it?
-Now are they self-supporting?
They’re going to be relaxed,
chilling out on the grass after a swim.
-Right.
-Then you don't have to do the legs.
Yeah, well, I’m not silly.
[Noel] Stacey’s French meringue flamingos
will perch over chocolate boxes
filled with raspberry and lemon mousse
and vanilla panna cotta,
guarding their Italian meringue nest.
I have practised this a lot.
I’m only going to try my best
and do what I can do.
Hold your hand out.
I’m okay. I don't really shake.
Oh. I am now, aren’t I?
I don't really shake.
So have got my Swiss meringue in there.
Using the thermometer
to gauge the temperature
and when it gets to 50 degrees,
take it off the heat.
I’m doing French meringue.
I’m just slowly
adding in tablespoons of caster sugar.
Want to make sure all of the sugar
dissolves in the egg whites,
otherwise it could leach or crack.
By the end it should be nice
and glossy and firm.
So mine’s actually going to be a tutu,
a ballet tutu.
So it’s just a kind of throwback
to my ballet days.
Long time ago now.
Think a lot of people
who maybe I served with
would have no idea that I could bake.
My dance friends couldn't believe
I was joining the army.
My army friends couldn't believe
I used to dance. Always surprising people.
[Sandi] Sophie’s tutu skirt will support
a nine-layer opera cake,
her supersized take
on the classic French coffee gateaux
encased in a Swiss meringue bodice.
Did you use to do ballet
when you were a little girl?
Did you? Did you like it?
I did, yeah. Not ever that little.
I did it until I was about 20.
When I was six my mother sent me
to the Royal Copenhagen Ballet School.
Oh, wow.
I had three lessons
and they asked me to leave.
-On what grounds?
-I was not any good at it.
Well, they let me do it for 20 years
before going, you’re really not...
Little bit tall for it as well.
Tall and a little bit wide as well.
[Sandi] For his ambitious design,
Steven’s been inspired by altogether
more cheerful childhood memories.
This whole design is based around the song
that our nana would sing to us.
The name of it
is "Some Air over the Rainbow"
and it’s a hot air balloon,
a rainbow hot air balloon.
[Noel] Suspended above
a lemon Italian meringue pie cloud
will be Steven’s multi-layered balloon,
loaded with macaroons, creams and curds
and made from a soft style
of French meringue.
I want that crunch, the powder and then...
-A little bit of softness.
-And the softness.
How are you going to suspend it?
Central dowel rod.
Each disc will sit through the dowel rod
but hopefully the shape of the piping
should reduce the cracking.
The cracking is the danger, isn’t it?
-Yeah.
-Very ambitious, Steven.
-I know.
-Who’s going in the basket?
Originally when I first thought this up,
I thought Paul, Prue, me, you but I think
I’ll just leave it empty.
-That’s quite poignant.
-It’s a drone. No one’s flying this one.
[Noel] Rainbows are rare enough.
Now I’m just adding a touch of colour
because it’s going to look
a pastel rainbow.
But this semi-final showstopper
has been graced by not one but two.
I think that’s the nature
of meringues, isn’t it?
They are bright, they are bold,
it’s a given that everyone
is going to be doing that sort of thing.
-Good morning, Kate.
-Morning.
Morning, Kate.
Tell us all about
your meringue centrepiece, please?
Okay, so I’m going to do
a meringue rainbow,
which is obviously
going to be multi-coloured,
going into two pots of gold.
-I’m looking forward to this rainbow.
-It’s a lovely idea.
[Sandi] Kate’s Swiss meringue rainbow
will stretch
over a sky of Italian meringue clouds,
carved fruit and meringue kisses.
And each rainbow colour
will have its own distinct flavour.
I am using natural extracts
in the meringue.
-What’s that colour?
-Indigo?
-That's going to be purple.
-I’m colour-blind actually.
-Are you?
-Yeah.
That would explain...quite a lot,
fashion-wise.
You know
you’re wearing a pink shirt now, right?
I’m doing red and orange,
which is going to make like a bright pink.
I like pink.
I do like pink.
Pink. Red. Orange. Yellow.
Green. Blue. Purple.
I think purists might have
something to say about it.
So two rainbows going on over there.
Yeah.
Flamingos here and a tutu, which is
the gayest challenge of all time.
It really is. It really is.
[birds chirping]
[Sandi] One hour gone.
Let’s get this started, shall we?
[Sandi] And piping can begin.
So I’m piping
the French meringue into little ruffles.
[Stacey] I am shaking, you know.
[Sandi] A steady hand is critical,
as imperfections now
could lead to unstable structures later.
[Kate] I’m just piping it on freehand.
Don't want it to crack.
[Sophie] The necks are super important,
really don't want cracks on these
because they've got
to stand up for themselves.
[Noel] And once meringue sets
there is no going back.
It’s just about
trying to create shape in there
because it should maintain this shape.
And this is going to form
the base of the tutu skirt.
The rainbow itself is like one piece.
Should be able to support itself.
[Steven] These are the central layers.
I don't want to think
about it falling over.
Worst nightmare for a baker.
This is Swiss meringue,
it’s good for things like sculpting.
Height of precision. Now...
You paint the inside of the piping bag
and it comes out like that.
I am now piping the bodice.
I don't actually have many tutus.
I performed, like, once in a tutu.
Just worried that it’s not quite
thick enough. I don't want it to crack.
I’m just colouring them.
Alright pinky Lee, I wrote a song
about a flamingo once.
-Did you?
-I'll sing it to you if you win.
I would love you to. Now they’re going in.
It’s more like a drying out process
than baking them really.
[Noel] A meringue’s texture can alter
radically depending on how long it bakes.
Low temperature for as long as I can.
[Noel] The longer the bake,
the chewier the middle
but the sturdier
the materials for building.
It’s going to be in the oven
for about two hours.
Let’s see what happens
after two hours.
Going to go in the oven for about
two and a half to three hours.
I’m doing these at 150 for an hour.
I tried it low and slow
and it just turns to toffee.
It’s not how I like meringue.
[Sandi] Meringues in the oven.
Dropping them on the floor.
It’s onto the dessert elements...
Blueberry jam.
Just getting that on the stove now.
...that should show off
their flair for flavour.
Cocktail time.
So this is a variation
of a cocktail called Lemon Drop.
So if you remember back to the song,
"Somewhere Over the Rainbow,"
your troubles melt like lemon drops.
So I’ve got my ganache.
So the hot cream has gone in there
and it’s just melting the chocolate.
I haven’t been to an actually ballet
for quite a while
but always staring at pictures and videos.
Making my raspberry mousse
and also my vanilla panna cotta.
If you’re going to do a flavour,
do a flavour.
Do you know what I mean?
If you’re going to put it in,
make sure they can taste it.
Passion fruits
always freak me out a little bit.
At what stage did someone decide
that they were going to eat that?
Chopping that
and then I’ll start on my cream.
-[Noel] Is this going in here?
-Yeah.
Yeah?
Yeah. Oh, no, hang on.
No? Is that the wrong one?
Can you imagine if you turn that on
and it went flying out?
-What would happen? Would it...
-Yeah, that’s it. It’s clicked in now.
Maybe we can take someone out.
Less competition.
[birds chirping]
I do a brilliant impersonation
of Paul. Listen to this.
[in Paul's voice] Bakers,
you're halfway through.
Yeah, we’re good to go.
Steven? Is that
all your meringue done already?
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
The meringues are cracked slightly
and I know that it might
come back and bite me.
[Noel] The more fracture lines
in the meringue...
Got some cracks already.
...the less stable their final structures.
Because of the dome shape,
it’s just pulled down
from the weight of the meringue.
Really annoying.
I don't have time really to faff around
redoing it so just go with it.
Just getting my ingredients ready
for my Italian meringue.
This is the last one.
I’m making the nest
out of Italian meringue
and I’m blowtorching it.
It’s just adding hot sugar
to whisked egg whites.
Suddenly got very hot in here again.
It’s unbelievably hot.
[Sandi] And if making meringue in
a sweltering tent wasn't tricky enough...
[Sophie] I’m like actually
really, really hot.
...two bakers are about to make
their own lives even harder.
Working with chocolate is not my thing.
I’ve not done this before.
I only need one egg.
This is the basket.
I thought the meringue was difficult,
working with chocolate is even worse.
Especially when it's
350 degrees Celsius outside.
I’m going to stick it in the freezer.
Be good if that works.
-I do a pretty mean Prue impression.
-Oh, yeah.
[in Prue's voice] Bakers,
you have one hour.
Okay, that’s really scary.
It’s coming out.
It could have been a bit neater
but I needed to get them in the oven.
[Noel] The bakers now face their most
nerve-wracking construction so far...
They’re very, very, very delicate.
[Steven] There’s a huge amount of risk
and meringue hates being touched.
...knowing just one slip of the hand,
and their delicate
building materials will shatter.
A lot of the fracture lines
I’m putting buttercream onto,
so hoping structurally
it should still work.
I’m going to check out my chocolate.
So I’m just going to whack it down.
This is just not working.
Ah. Oh my God.
Oh, I did crack it.
I cracked my head off.
The fact that it’s sticking to another
one will hopefully be alright.
I’m just like decorating it now.
Just using gold dust to just give it
a little bit of a sheen.
The heat is killing me. The pressure’s on.
Most of them have got a bit of cracking.
Stacey, one of her
flamingo necks cracked.
This I managed to put back on.
Still not set.
[Paul] I’ve noticed Sophie’s
is cracked quite badly.
The intricacy is quite impressive.
Going to be a bit of a frenzy
assuming nothing goes wrong now.
Looking at the colours in Kate’s,
I think the vibrancy’s there.
Steven’s looks quite a weight
to be held up.
I’m not clear
on how this is going to look.
Or whether it will all stay together.
Little bit stressful.
[Sandi] From now on, every action
could make or break the centrepieces...
Going to start assembling the insides.
...as each element added puts more strain
on their fragile meringue.
I’ve got the ganache and then a mousse.
Do that three times.
Bakers, you have half an hour.
Just 30 minutes remaining, bakers.
This is supposed to be a nest.
Right, creams. Not a lot of time left.
Little bit of a gap.
That’s cracked as well now. Oh, right.
That’s not good. Not good at all.
Ah, not great.
This is the mousse.
Pretty hot in here now.
[Steven] The heat’s starting
to rise a little bit
and I can hear it around the room as well.
[Noel] Are you all right?
Lot of cracks. Going to try
and cover them up.
[Steven] Oh, look at my basket.
Ugh.
That’s how hot it is in here.
It is literally melting chocolate.
It’s holding.
Okay, bakers, you have five minutes.
Five minutes.
This is horrible to watch.
I’m worried about this one
because it’s got a crack in it.
It’s just siting quite nicely on itself.
Stop faffing around with it.
That's what we need to do.
It’s very, very fiddly.
Start piping anywhere
where there is a sort of hole or crack.
Oh, that crack is bad, isn’t it?
Just got to get the clouds on.
They’re supposed to be kissing.
Oh, my God.
I hate rushing.
One minute left.
[Steven] Oh.
Do not crack on me.
Bakers, unfortunately your time is up.
Step away from your Showstopper.
Please put your Showstoppers
at the end of your benches.
[Noel] The semi-finalists'
meringue centrepieces
now face the judgement of Prue and Paul.
My Showstopper wasn't as good
as it has been but hopefully it’s enough.
[Stacey] It doesn't look too bad.
If this is the end of the road for me,
I’m leaving happy with what I’ve done.
[Kate] I don't really know
how it stands up to anyone else’s.
All I know is the rainbow stands up.
There’s so much there that’s wrong.
I hope they see the effort
that went into it.
Sophie, please bring up
your meringue centrepiece.
Wow.
Looks like a hat.
[Sandi] Oh, no, it’s not, it’s a tutu.
-It just looks like a hat.
-I would love to see you wear that.
What, the tutu or the hat?
Seriously, I’m game for both.
[Paul] I think
the design is very, very good.
I think your piping is good.
I think the bake on the bottom,
is that the French meringue?
Yes.
It's split an awful lot.
Wow.
Very nice meringue.
The Swiss and the French is very good.
Baked well as well.
Crispy, which is what
you need to be the base.
How many layers
have you got to this opera cake?
Nine, I think.
It should be seven.
Well, I had to fill it up.
Is that not good?
It tastes amazing.
The coffee mousse lightens it up
because the ganache is quite heavy
because it’s so thick.
If you had done the ganache
a little thinner
it would have been ten out of ten.
Well, I’m highly impressed.
-Awesome.
-Very well done.
-Thank you very much.
-Thank you.
Phew. Thank God for that.
Kate, would you like to bring up
your meringue Showstopper please.
[Prue] Oh, wow.
-Wow.
-It’s colourful. Bit childish.
And the colours are just amazing.
They just shine out at you.
I just love the look of it.
I think it’s fantastic.
The rainbow itself is a little uneven.
-Needed to be neater.
-Yeah.
Every single colour
is a different fruit flavour.
Definitely raspberry. I like that.
Yeah, I get the different flavours.
They're a bit like sweets.
I think it’s wonderful.
I’ve got and Italian meringue
on the bottom,
which I’ve lightly blowtorched.
Delicious.
The flavours, the creams, the Swiss
meringue are all absolutely lovely.
It’s a bit of
a splat of flavour and colour.
For me it sort of
freaks me out a little bit.
You have to release your mind.
This is absolute celebration of fruit
and cream and meringue.
That is Kate on a plate.
Yeah.
-[Prue] I love that. Well done, Kate.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
[Noel] Stacey, would you like to bring
your meringue Showstopper up to the table?
A centrepiece needs to be
easily recognisable for what it is.
They are obviously birds.
It’s quite simplistic
but you’ve thought it through well.
I hope it tastes as good as it looks.
-It’s a nice meringue that.
-Mmm. Very good.
It’s chewy.
Now this is the Italian meringue.
It’s just too sweet and sticky.
And you can only bear
a little bit of that.
[Paul] It’s just very, very soft.
One is filled with a vanilla panna cotta
and raspberry coulis
and the other one is filled
with a raspberry lemon mousse.
-It’s like a takeaway dish isn’t it?
-It is. It is.
It’s probably not
the best thing in the world
but it’s very practical for what it does.
-It’s just very tart.
-[Stacey] Sorry, too much coulis.
It’s very nice.
You have the sweetness underneath.
It’s very creamy.
[Paul] That’s quite tart as well.
All of that meringue is so sweet,
you really do need
something sharp to go with it.
-Well done, Stacey.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
Steven, please bring up
your meringue centrepiece.
It was a hot air balloon and a basket.
It got too close to the sun.
Icarus.
Exactly. Yes.
The colours are just lovely.
I love those pastel shades.
I imagine if the chocolate basket
was still intact, you’d get it.
-Yes.
-But just looking at that,
I would think it was a tree.
-Psychedelic tree.
-Yeah, a psychedelic tree.
-I wouldn’t think it was a balloon.
-What happened with the cracking?
It took one crack
and then the weight just...did that.
That shouldn't have happened.
If you make a centrepiece you need it
to last for four or five hours.
[Paul] Okay.
So the top one is an Eton Mess?
Balsamic, strawberry and a clotted cream.
The flavour’s nice.
Execution? Probably not and that
comes down to the bake.
What you should've done was bake it
for longer to dry it out totally
to give it a more stable base.
It’s such a pity,
because it’s so delicious.
Now this is the Italian?
That’s the Italian meringue
with the lemon drop pie.
It’s so good.
It’s great. Very light.
Love the flavours. They taste amazing.
I mean, beautiful.
I just think the method,
the way you’ve done it
is not up to normal Steven standard.
-Thank you, Steven.
-Thank you.
[Noel] Prue and Paul must now decide
who deserves Star Baker
and who must miss out
on the chance to become champion.
Showstopper. It’s the semi-final.
Couldn't be more important.
Who stood out for you?
I really liked Kate’s
because it looks fantastic.
The colours are wonderful.
I thought the flavours
and textures, spot on.
What about Sophie?
Sophie showed
the most skill in the Showstopper.
With the meringue,
which is perfectly baked
and exactly the right texture.
So does that mean that Sophie
and Kate are both in line for Star Baker?
-Yes. But it is ridiculously tight.
-It is tight.
I have to say I’m really none the wiser
in terms of who is going to be leaving us.
Coming into today, Stacey
was in a very difficult position.
She was down at the bottom.
I think when you break it down,
what she’s done is very simple.
She’s piped a flamingo, baked them off
and leaned them against
a couple of puddings.
But it does look like a centrepiece
and it tastes delicious.
I think Steven has been so ambitious
that he hasn't quite achieved it.
I love the colours
and I love the flavours.
[Noel] The flavours.
If it’s not clear cut,
which is seems it isn’t,
do you then give yourselves
the luxury of having a look back?
Initially, we’ve got to look
at this weekend very closely
and if that still doesn't
draw any obvious answers
and it's so close then yes.
We have to look back retrospectively
on the whole series.
It’s only happened a couple of times.
This is utterly horrifying. It’s so close.
You just don't want
to make the wrong decision.
I just wanted to say
before you hear the results,
this has been the hardest decision that
I’ve been involved with in eight years.
Right, let’s start with the good news.
So I get to announce Star Baker.
This was a person
who delivered on Misérables,
made everybody extremely happy,
who danced away with the Showstopper.
This week’s Star Baker is Sophie.
Thank you.
Well done.
That means I’ve got
the horrible job of announcing
which one of you guys is not going
to make it to the final,
which at this stage,
I know is the cruellest blow.
It was so tight as Paul said.
Sadly, the person who won’t be joining us
in the final is...
Stacey.
-I’m sorry.
-Okay.
-Sorry, darling.
-It’s okay.
So close.
You did an amazing job. An amazing job.
I’m pleased I’ve gone out on a high.
You know,
it was a really, really difficult decision
for them and that's great.
I think Stacey should be really,
really proud of what she’s achieved.
I mean, she’ll be disappointed today
but the truth is she has done
something remarkable.
I can go back to
being a good mum so it’s okay.
Could have waited another week
but it’s fine.
It’s fine.
I had accepted my fate.
I was going. I was going home.
But I’m in the finals. I can’t,
I cannot believe it. I cannot believe it.
We have three great bakers
going into the final.
They’re exciting, they’re vibrant,
they bring new flavours,
new textures into the tent.
I think the final should be amazing.
Thanks. Cheers mate.
Got Star Baker in week nine
but it’s now all about the final.
So actually, what happened today kind of
doesn't mean anything any more
because what about next week?
Expecting someone to come over and go,
we’re only messing.
Go on, off you go.
You’ve made it through to the final.
-Hiya, Dad, you okay?
-Hi, Kate, you okay?
I got put through to the final.
[Kate's dad exclaiming]
Nine weeks of trying harder
than I’ve ever tried in my life.
I want this more than anything.
I think they were happy for me.
[theme music playing]